Mexicans are I'm not even gonna lie to
you even over Filipinos my favorite
people in the world now right they're my
favorite people too as long as they're
citizens coming over the wall from
Juarez no I'm a person I think I live in
my life in the gray zone where it's like
listen I got I I I'm all for the walls
stupid I don't [ __ ] what that's a
[ __ ] dumb idea but it's like you know
yeah I want everybody to be safe so it's
like you can't let everybody in without
some type of nice you know system where
we can verify things and just that's
fine of course but let everybody this is
America I got no problem with that but
it's like if you say that dog you
[ __ ] Republican [ __ ] it's like no no
baby I'm trying I got you you instable
you can sit because people with three
four roommates you know that they
[ __ ] that they're kids they're saying
they're cats they're their cat parents
they're yelling about the politics it's
like you don't know what you're talking
about babe I pay taxes I own a home you
don't [ __ ] know about you don't have
any idea you're sitting around
commiserating you're you telling me
about I saw this one guy yelling on
Twitter about what's gonna happen if the
Supreme Court justice sways this way and
all and like you're just regurgitating
articles you [ __ ] googled and these
thing is he works for FedEx it's like go
[ __ ] and deliver the packages baby just
mail me my [ __ ] okay take a seat honey
yeah let the people we voted and just do
their jobs and trust in the system and
that's it Hitler came to power don't ask
questions yeah that's it you know yeah
I'll put some people in camps yeah but
the people that are the people that are
most offended by it are people that live
like in the middle of the country right
that aren't affected as much as we are
in the cities right and we don't make
that big of a huge like what's the gang
ms-13 but yeah yeah Emma stirred I've
lived by ms-13 gang members in
Silverlake we all do this is LA
Wow morning good morning it's like
people yeah but that's the thing when
you were saying it's like the people in
the middle of the country they everybody
if it really affects you like people
don't care we figure out ways to deal
with it like even me like it happened to
me I was on this show on Netflix and I
got fired for a joke because there was
an international like competition and
the Chinese team was competing and they
fell off the obstacle course into the
water and they called it the beast blood
and say that I hit the competitors name
was bin Fung yeah and I said there goes
bin Fung into the duck sauce and the
hypocrisy was I get fired whatever for
that I got fired but bin Fung bin Fung
retweeted the the clip of me saying that
bin Fung who I said it about was very
happy it's like hilarious it's so funny
a lot of you want to come to my comedy
shows but I got fired by this fat white
woman named Barbara
yeah it's because Barbara has to [ __ ]
stand up for China it's wonderful you're
fat [ __ ] you have duck sauce on your
fingertips so it's the same thing with
the middle of the country talking about
the it's like everybody wants to do the
job for everybody else like relax man
like yeah relax like you know we don't
have to do all these things like you
have to hire a black man and a woman
that demeans them we're all equal that's
yes yes
you know like let everybody be fair and
square rot we're 2020 it's like I
understand there's still subtle racism
in and or maybe major racism in parts of
the country but it's like we get it like
come on man like you know just show
business it's hard for everyone right
even in like in 1999 yeah when I got mad
TV they didn't want an Asian right
they'd never had one they even said no
he's not gonna get it right right and
then when I did get it you know right
it felt there was no movement or we I
was you know Asia's weren't the it thing
all right but I still had the
opportunity yeah and I hit it out of the
[ __ ] park
yeah and I got it I got yeah and that's
America
it's American support for everyone it's
hard for everyone and even like
even like where I come from like deep
Brooklyn like I got a father like a
[ __ ] father that was like in and out
of jail like deep Brooklyn father I've
never heard that man and you would see
you would see this guy in a TV show I
call that guy's the most racist guy ever
I've never heard that man
utter a racial slur unless his team
didn't cover the spread but uh but you
know but other than that he's just kind
he's open his doors when there was a big
flood uh hurricane sandy devastated New
York in 2012 and Staten Island got
ravaged and my father's house was a
little inland so my father but the
houses on the shore got destroyed mostly
mostly Latino families and my dad went
rented a u-haul truck every single day
and went down and helped them and do all
that and even had two different families
live in his house for two weeks each
took their kids to school and all that
but my dad just from a time so he's
doing the right thing my gadgets from a
time though we're like he likes to have
like little jokes like you forgot the
the leader of the family that the father
his name was Juan my dad called him Jose
he did just didn't give a [ __ ] he would
be like Oh hide the silverware like old
school dad hack jokes you know be like
you know like are you in a gang you know
kids three years old like [ __ ] like that
you know but but he see act was I'm
gonna help because I love people so so
when you try to take awake words now in
comedy it's like somebody would call
some like woke [ __ ] social justice
where he would want to like tie my dad
up and [ __ ] burn him at the stake
cookies of which it's like he's doing
more for the community in turn a claim
to push racism back and push progress
forward than you ever could if you just
want hurt people sorry to interrupt but
we have some amazing sponsors you want
to share with yeah